et le combat de trop c'est un titre
un cliché une expression familière en
matière de boxe et pas seulement du box
en matière de sport tous ceux qui ont
admiré la grâce l'intelligence la force
de celui qui s'appelait cassius clay qui
décida de se faire rebaptiser mohamed
ali celui qui fut un roi des poids
lourds de la boxe mondiale et dont la
vivacité d'esprit l'intelligence de
langage
lorsqu'il rencontrait les hommes d'état
des journalistes frappe est étonné le
monde tous ceux qui ont suivi cette
carrière exceptionnelle se désole de le
voir revenir sur un ring ce soir aux
bahamas pour ce que l'on peut appeler un
combat doute alain tolère commente
quelques images mohamed ali fêtera ses
40 ans le 17 janvier prochain
trois fois champion du monde des poids
lourds il rend compte cette nuit aux
bahamas le canadien trevor berbick 4e
mondial pour une bourde 500 millions de
centimes
ali qui n'a pas boxé depuis 78 s'expose
à d'énormes risques face à un garçon de
28 ans vous allez voir si c'est un
miracle vous allez voir ce que je vais
en faire je vais le réduire à rien mais
il ya un danger réel d'hémorragie aussi
rouge et demeure immédiate
c'est dix mois que c'est impossible que
je suis fini dites moi que je suis trop
mieux allez-y dit tout cela la télé que
tout le monde en sera bien convaincu que
j'ai tant qu'à faire il se trouve qu'on
pousse vous verrez vraiment j'adore ça
alors oui je ne sais pas il doit se
prouver à lui même c'est difficile à
comprendre
pour n'importe qui mais c'est ce qu'il
veut madame à lille épouse de mohammed
c'est que son mari est dans une
situation très très délicate et tente de
l'expliquer il est têtu d'accord tout le
monde lui dit d'arrêter et cela
encourage d'autant plus à continuer
s'ils veulent vraiment qu'ils arrêtent
qu'il le laisse tranquille
il s'arrêtera quand bon lui semblera
obama selon murmure que don king le
manager dalli se s'est fait tabasser
après avoir rendu une discrète visite à
berbie une correction qui tendrait à
prouver que berbick a refusé l'argent
offert pour se coucher devant ali ali
107 kg berbick 98 résultat cette nuit